seria possível as nossas casas
produzirem mais energia do que elas
consomem
eu vou contar que a experiência de um
grupo de estudantes que construiu uma
casa solar capaz de gerar o do mais do
dobro de energia que os seus moradores
necessitam
eu ainda lembro bem de quando eu o
sentia água eo vento batendo no meu
rosto quando velejava adolescente e
buscava melhorar a velocidade do meu
barco ajustando a diferença está o mar e
do do vento
mas o que mais me interessava mesmo era
as competições
eu passava a a semana estudando em
livros de velejadores consagrados e me
preparando fisicamente para as regatas
dos finais de semana
essas regatas eram geralmente muito
disputadas e eu na maioria das vezes eu
não consegui a primeira colocação mas
isso pra mim não era o mais importante
é difícil explicar essa motivação para
pessoas que não participaram ativamente
de competições
é nesses campeonatos existiam um clima
muito especial e que era reforçado pelas
amizades e laís troca de experiências e
era possível então eu comparar com os
outros velejadores as minhas estratégias
mas as regulagens do barco e e as amo
meu desempenho naquelas condições de
vento e de indícios de mar é essas
possibilidades eram muito importantes
como aprendizado para as competições
seguintes
essa motivação é o que a gente estava
tentando levar para os estudantes neste
trabalho a a história do team brasil não
é uma história nova acontece com pelo
menos 20 equipes em diferentes países
todo ano o que tem de novidade é que
pela primeira vez uma equipe
latino-americana participou de um evento
do solar de cabo e o que é o solar de
carro
é uma conta com uma competição acadêmica
de casas solares eficientes e
sustentáveis e que os alunos devem
está a construir levar essa casa o local
da competição e chegando lá operá-la
simulando a o funcionamento de uma casa
tradicional a as três características
mais importantes desse evento são a
inovação a colaboração ea integração
entre as diferentes áreas e o fato do
celular de cadu não ser uma competição é
realmente importante
nós acreditamos que sim e esperarão
especialmente para sua eficácia como
instrumento de aprendizagem
nesse sentido duas questões são centrais
a paixão que move aqueles atletas
amadores é muito parecida daqui faz com
que esses alunos é busquem superar
barreiras é eles procuram assim
encontrar o seu conseguir um desempenho
melhor e melhores resultados através de
da busca por soluções mais inovadoras e
também pelo estabelecimento de equipes
mais colaborativas
além disso esses grandes campeonatos
eles constituem redes
entre os participantes que ajudam na
troca de experiências e informações na
preparação durante e também após após
esses eventos
eu vou contar rapidamente é como é que
nós acabamos indo pra pra esse evento e
em 2008 nós começamos a explorar a
grande quantidade de material disponível
nos sites do solar decathlon pra os
nossos cursos do projeto é neste momento
uma possível participação no no evento
que acontecerá em washington em 2011
parecia quase impossível
entretanto um grupo de espanhóis que
estava organizando o primeiro a primeira
edição do solar decathlon a europa fez
um convite para uma equipe uma equipe
brasileira
isso aconteceu em 2001
seria em 2010 nós então isso mudou os
nossos planos e nós começamos a nos
preparar pra essa edição e conseguimos
um apoio da eletrobrás que foi bastante
importante mas ele chegou muito tarde e
entretanto esse apoio junto com outras
empresas foi determinante para a nossa
participação então em 2012 em 2010 então
nós realizamos um novo projeto pra o dae
com house que seria o primeiro
representante brasileiro no solar da
solar decathlon europe 2012 a a
organização ea coordenação desse projeto
ela foi compartilhada entre a
universidade federal de santa catarina
ea universidade de são paulo e contou
com a colaboração da ufrj e da unicamp
mais de 200 alunos participaram neste
projecto desde 2008 e mais de 30 foram
finalmente para madri para participar da
competição
e qual é a grande contribuição para o
processo de ensino
esses alunos eles assumiram uma posição
de protagonistas
eles ocuparam é diversas funções de
liderança durante todas as etapas do
processo e isso não é uma condição muito
comum dos nossos alunos
além disso eles tiveram uma oportunidade
rara na universidade de poder projetar
uma casa de grande eficiência a depois
disso eles simularam essas casas é esse
projetos e buscando alternativas
melhores atestaram também diferentes
formas de construção e finalmente eles
construíram essa casa e construíram para
levar com uma competição junto com
várias outras equipes que tiveram
experiências muito semelhantes ea
construção da casa foi feito em são
paulo e grupo de alunos é e se juntaram
aos estudantes da usp em três
oportunidades e eles lá cursarão
disciplinas
enquanto desenvolviam as atividades de
projeto
planejamento e da construção da casa é o
primeiro grupo de alunos ele foi eles
foram para são paulo para participar da
do desenvolvimento do projeto e da
viabilidade econômica da proposta
um novo grupo é foi pra são paulo então
para continuar com o desenvolvimento do
projeto e trabalhando começando a
fabricação dos componentes da casa
finalmente o terceiro grupo que a gente
vê nesse vídeo eles foram pra para são
paulo um semestre antes do início da
competição ele foram para construir a
casa ea maioria deles integrou então a
equipe que foi para madri participar da
competição
há um outro desafio que a equipe tinha
era como viabilizar a eco house a num
país como o brasil em que esse custo
ainda é bastante elevado para os
próprios padrões de residência
brasileiros
nós pensamos então a que além disso
seria muito importante que essa casa
tivesse um reduzido impacto ambiental e
trouxesse grandes ganhos sociais
isso seria muito difícil para uma casa
para uma pessoa se nós ampliamos essa
casa para uma família ainda assim não
seria muito simples nós decidimos então
fazer eco house com uma residência
temporária que se que fosse projetado
foi projetada pra a pousadas localizadas
em áreas de com o ecossistema as frágeis
e que é elas não tivessem acesso à
energia elétrica
o custo dessa casa seria então
compartilhado por um grande número de
pessoas
ela traria ganhos importantes econômicos
para as comunidades da região e além
disso promoveria hábitos mais
sustentáveis para os seus hóspedes é co
significa maneira de viver em
tupi-guarani a proposta arquitetônica
ela parte de um módulo mínimo que possui
isolamento muito eficiente e que pode
ser condicionado artificialmente
ele se expande por uma área de varandas
que ajuda a filtrar os raios solares e
também a controlar a privacidade dos
moradores
as varandas são elementos tradicionais
da casa brasileira ela ajuda a conectar
os moradores com um ambiente natural
elas servem como transição entre o
espaço mais privado e fechado e o espaço
mais social em contato com a natureza
recorra aos possui 48 painéis
fotovoltaicos de alta eficiência que são
capazes de gerar mais do dobro da
energia necessária para os hóspedes
o excedente então ele é direcionado para
a comunidade da região e pode é suprir
pelo menos há a necessidade mais uma
família
a cobertura é compartilhada ainda com
coletores solares que garantem toda a
água quente da casa ea cobertura ainda
coleta a água da chuva
toda a água da casa ela é tratada por um
sistema de raízes que devolve essa água
para o meio pro para a natureza sem
prejuízo isso é possível porque a casa
possui o vaso seco é que realiza todo o
processo de compostagem localmente
a casa possui ainda um sistema de
automação informação é que conecta todos
os outros sistemas da casa a uma estação
meteorológica local é essa e isso ajuda
a a a e faz com que os moradores tenham
uma noção do impacto ambiental de cada
uma das suas atividades e faz com que
eles a já comecem a ajustar essas
atividades
as variações da natureza a construção da
casa ela foi feita de uma maneira que
pudesse simplificá a montagem dela em
madrid e também nos locais mais remotos
para onde a casa foi projetada no brasil
após a a construção da casa ela foi
então embalada e colocada em containers
para o seu transporte de são paulo
paulo até madri duas semanas antes do
início da competição os primeiros
caminhões puderam então entrar no local
das provas
as equipes européias principalmente
levaram grandes volumes com a casa
praticamente pronta
isso seria um custo muito alto para o
brasil então esse transporte de navio
por isso nós decidimos é que a construir
a casa em painéis o que levou mais tempo
e exigiu mais trabalho da equipe
a equipe após a montagem desse módulo
central ela ela se dividiu entre e no
com o trabalho na parte externa enquanto
outro grupo trabalhava no seu interior
a complexidade da construção exigiu
também que a equipe trabalhasse à noite
e espaços como a cozinha só puderam ser
começado nos últimos dias finalmente a
casa pode ser concluída ea rampa foi a
última parte a ser feita com o ajuste
dela com o terreno possibilitando assim
o amplo acesso até a casa
o interior da casa ele traz aspectos da
cultura brasileira especialmente através
dos móveis um renomado designer
brasileiro que que doou para o evento
após o término da construção as equipes
então comemoraram na cerimônia de
abertura quando iniciou a a competição e
também as visitações
neste momento somente os alunos poderiam
ficar nas casas
eles eram responsáveis por todos os
tratou do trabalho e eles a organizava
então as visitas e explicavam o
funcionamento da record aos esse evento
teve um recorde é de participantes
contando com 220 mil pessoas que
visitaram todas as casas dessas pessoas
cerca de 2.000 a universitários 6 mil
profissionais e mais de 5 mil crianças
tiveram visitas especialmente feitas
para eles
durante toda a competição essas casas
elas foram monitoradas e isso aparecia
em tempo real no site do evento e podia
ser acessado por qualquer pessoa
aqui a gente vê por exemplo a
a geração da dayco house e quanto dessas
dessa energia aquela gerada ela era
consumida na casa e quanto era lançado
para a rede pública
a classificação também era atualizada
automaticamente a gente vê aqui o final
do primeiro dia quando a equipe
brasileira terminou em primeiro lugar
só que como as minhas gatas essa
primeira colocação não durou muito tempo
háháhá os alunos também deviam simular o
funcionamento da casa
o como a a temperatura do banho não
podia ser avaliada no banho de um dos
alunos é é a água necessária para esse
banho era então colocada num
reservatório duas vezes por dia e em
outras situações os alunos precisavam
preparar jantares dessa vez de verdade
para os próprios membros das equipes
vizinhas e também e um jantar nas casas
dos concorrentes
outras é outros encontros informais
ajudavam a a troca de experiências ea a
competição ela era dividida em provas
objetivas que eram avaliadas por
sensores e pô é é a realização de
tarefas como a do banho por exemplo em
outros casos as subjetivas que eram
avaliadas a por um membro de jurados que
assistiam à apresentação dos alunos e
discutiam com eles as estratégias da
equipe
numa delas a prova de sustentabilidade a
equipe brasileira conseguiu seu melhor
resultado ganhando o prêmio de terceiro
lugar após mais de um mês de trabalho
intenso as casas então começaram a ser
desmontadas e nós estamos num momento de
muito especial para o brasil e que nós
reconhecemos o direito universal à
moradia é importante nesse momento a
gente questionar se nós estamos
realmente preparando profissionais
capazes de ir através de ações positivas
construir uma nova ética
o que nós vemos nas imagens a equipe é
após a conclusão da desmontagem e na
é hora de voltar no brasil esses alunos
não parecem esgotados pelo contrário é
uma demonstração de que a paixão
permaneceu e que eles estão prontos para
novos desafios
obrigado